i wanted to do a show about how the
world might end so that we
don't let the world end
[Music]
the end is nigh is the show about
disasters that would end the world for
almost everybody the development process
started with my partner seth macfarlane
it's like he's never seen toilet paper
before he
asked to meet with bill nye he's our cow
oh you're a cow nye
so he says we gotta scare people
so we got to talking about it and we
came up with this idea wouldn't it be
better if things were not disastrous
for better or for worse we humans are
good at drilling into the earth and
dressing up our pets like people and
then brandon braga took the idea and
developed it further making it not just
science fiction but science fact i spent
15 years doing star trek
and it's a lot easier when you can make
stuff up
you know everything that we talk about
on the show has been vetted by multiple
scientists who are leaders in their
field my esteemed colleague is a storm
analyst talking to the national
hurricane center branch chief and other
government agencies
the show starts out with setting up the
disaster a volcano one thousand times
the size of mount st helens is about to
erupt
the disasters are serious business
people
what they're calling a potential super
flare i'm not talking about pants from
the 1970s we cover all sorts of
disasters everything from solar flares
taking out the planet's power grid to a
super volcano erupting to five giant
hurricanes hitting the world at once not
today fluffy and then at the end of the
first half i get killed
oh that's the most fun part of this show
i get to kill bill six times
volcano night
it's a blast well you have to watch the
show but stuff goes wrong man look out
but then in the second half i come back
how could we avoid this disaster what
could we do about this let's put systems
in place let's address this issue
optimistic view of the future through
science
geothermal is a clean source of energy
that we will never deplete it will be
available for as long as earth exists we
want to empower people with knowledge
and knowledge conquers fear
yes let's not live in denial let's
accept the idea that there are at least
six catastrophes that could happen and
let's prepare for them let's not let
them happen and plus it's cool it's
exciting and fun
saving the world
let's go
[Music]
you